Morbius appeared first as an antagonist
in the amazing spider-man in 1971
and eventually evolved into more of an
anti-hero if you're gonna run do it now
for years before that marvel was actually
forbidden from using characters considered
more on the supernatural side so it was a really
big deal when morbius finally made his debut
there's something inside of me who wants to hunt
and consume blood he was part of a much darker
turn within marvel one that fortunately fans
fully embraced after all everyone loves
a good monster story there's something
about the character that stoked people's
imaginations it really can grab a hold of you
that certainly did with me
in the film version of morbius that we're bringing
to you now he's also a part of a much larger
universe if you've seen the last spider-man
no way home trailer you know the multiverse
has officially opened and there's all kinds of
opportunities for villains to meet up thrive
and maybe even nurture their more sinister intense
that's all i'm going to say for right now
Welcome back everyone this is my new morbius trailer
video one of a couple new trailers we're actually
getting even more morbius footage next week of
course i'll do a video for that too there's a
whole bunch of spider-man easter eggs here for
all the versions of spider-man tom holland mcu
spider-man toby maguire andrew garfield spider-man
as well as tom hardy's venom so we'll break it
all down and how everything is connected after
spider-man no way home thank you very much doctor
strange and spider-man for breaking the multiverse
so that we can have all these crossovers tell that
multiverse illuminati not to be too hard on doctor
strange we really wanted all these crossovers
if you're new to the channel i'm doing a giveaway
for the new spider-man no way home blu-rays they
just announced there's a whole bunch of extra
footage of toby maguire andrew garfield in matt
murdock daredevil all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and post all your theories about
how morbius is going to be connected to the mcu
given what they just explained in spider-man no
way home with the multiverse crossing over clearly
from that clip that i put at the beginning of this
jared leto is saying that they are going to be
doing some big sinister six crossovers in the
movies in the future and crossover with the mcu
tell me you're crossing over with everyone without
telling me you're crossing over there's a whole
lot going on in this new morbius footage too a lot
of new footage of matt smith's villain character
we finally got some details from sony about him so
i'll explain what's going on with his character
but the big thing here is which universe is the
morbius movie taking place in and how do they set
him up for spider-man sinister six crossovers with
venom crossovers any other versions of sinister
six characters are going to do in the future
and mcu characters like blade because of course we
want to see morbius the living vampire crossover
with blade the vampire hunter how can you not
do that sure you're ready for that mr whitman
so after spider-man no way home we still
have what you would consider the core mcu
movies like spider-man no way home all the stuff
that kevin feige makes personally with just the
marvel studios people sometimes in collaboration
with sony then you have all the tobey maguire
spider-man movies the andrew garfield spider-man
movies then all the sony driven venom movies and
spider-man spin-off movies with all the
sinister six characters that they control
technically all those take place in different
universes venom let there be carnage is the best
example that if someone doesn't understand
how things are connected just show them the
venom let there be carnage post-credits scene
in the spider-man no way home post-credits scene
like see he's over on a different universe
he jumps over quickly to the mcu earth then
comes right back is a really easy template for
how they're gonna do crossovers in the future
but technically because of what doctor strange
and mcu spider-man did in no way home with the
two different spells technically everything all
these different versions of spider-man different
versions of characters different universes are now
canon to the mcu so we should be calling it the
marvel cinematic multiverse but because there are
so many people making so many movies they do have
to keep it straight behind the scenes which is
why they still kind of consider the mcu separate
from the sony films at least on a structural level
so for instance the morbius movie is taking place
in the same universe the same earth as the venom
movies who the hell are you mad i am i know
they're driving creative on most of those films
it would make sense they put all their films
on the same earth just to make crossovers simpler
to understand so when you see michael keaton's
mcu vulture show up hyping a sinister six team up
like hey michael morbius we should stay in touch
putting together a team technically that makes
him an alternate universe version of vulture
who just looks and seems very similar to the
original mcu vulture from spider-man homecoming
like he's dressed the same he's meant to feel
the same but because of the way they explain
these multiverse crossovers he would be a variant
of mcu vulture because in this scene where morbius
is being hauled into prison and they cross paths
he is still on his original earth in that venom
universe he hasn't come to the main mcu earth
yet yet that's the important thing to remember
like during all of venom let there be carnage he
was on his original earth until the very end of
the post-credits scene there are a ton of andrew
garfield and toby mcguire easter eggs in this like
the tobey maguire spider-man suit and the version
of the daily bugles toby maguires but the version
of oscorp looks like andrew garfield's one from
the amazing spider-man 2 and in that daily bugle
newspaper they reference rhino and black cat to
characters feature during andrew garfield's movies
but again i think it's the same explainer as it
is for the tom holland mcu spider-man references
in this universe where morbius and venom come from
on their earth they have a version of spider-man
who wears or at one point wore a costume that
looks similar to tobey maguire's costume they have
a version of ozcorp in this universe that looks
kind of like andrew garfield's and some of the
same sinister six villains but it's not literally
meant to be the earth where tobey maguire comes
from or where andrew garfield spider-man came from
now their version of spider-man in the morbius and
venom universe might be an andrew garfield variant
for instance he might still look like andrew
garfield underneath that costume but he'd still
be a variant technically there's another trailer
scene where tyrese's character and the police
are referencing the stuff quote-unquote that
went down in san francisco recently that's them
referencing the events of venom lithiby carnage
just confirming that this takes place in the
same universe as venom it's only when it comes
to the legacy franchises like the tobey maguire
spider-man movies the andrew garfield amazing
spider-man movies in the core mcu movies that they
have to use the multiverse crossover to sort of
bring all these characters together so they don't
wind up retconning any big plot details about
tobey maguire spider-man or andrew garfield
spider-man and given what they did with the
venomolothe carnage post-credits scene bringing
him to the mcu using doctor strange's spell
then sending him back to his original universe in
the spider-man no way home post-credit scene with
doctor strange's second spell my early theory
right now is it'll be almost the exact same
situation with the morbius character they'll have
some kind of morbius post-credit scene or a tag
scene at the end where they tease him briefly
crossing over into the mcu for a hot minute
then coming back to the venom universe as for all
the new footage of matt smith's villain character
in this in the movie he's supposed to be playing a
version of loxias crown from the comics also known
as hunger sony confirmed that they've changed
his backstory a little and in the movie they're
just calling him lucian and milo two different
names his new backstory in this is that he's a
childhood friend of morbius they grow up together
he's born with the name lucian into this really
wealthy family but morbius befriends him and
renames him milo so for most of the film when
they're together he just calls him milo matt smith
said that because of the genetic disorder that he
suffers from the both of them suffer from and
because he's rich he grows up basically just
living life to the extreme spending money left and
right trying to metaphorically suck the marrow out
of life so you see where i'm going with this they
both become scientists trying to find a way to
cure their genetic disorder morbius finds the cure
it turns him into the morbius comic book character
giving him his powers and matt smith's character
steals the serum that he develops uses on himself
and that turns him into a version of hunger from
the comics with the same basic vampire-like powers
and he starts literally sucking the marrow out of
life in the comics hunger was an agent of hydra
who captured morbius to experiment on him and they
both wound up disappearing in this giant explosion
at the end of the issue later he reappears as
the hunger character with the same vampire-like
powers as morbius all these scenes seem like
matt smith's character learning about morbius
after his transformation what's happened to him
and then just stealing the serum for himself
the way matt smith explained it is that morbius
is afraid of his powers because they're trying
to play him like an anti-hero he doesn't want to
hurt people but his character his milo villain
character embraces the powers goes completely
off the rails and starts killing a bunch of
innocent people and that's why morbius has to
take him down you can see matt smith using his
hunger powers here when he blasts morbius back
with his shock wave on the street so it's not
too dissimilar from what happened with venom
let the be carnage in the carnage origin story
but like i said they're going to be releasing
the next big morbius trailer on monday with a
bunch more footage more andrew garfield more tobey
maguire easter eggs tom holland mcu easter eggs
i'll post my video as soon as they release it make
sure you have alerts enabled for my channel to be
the first to watch that and i'll be keeping the
blu-ray giveaway open in all my marvel videos in
the next month while we get ready for moon knight
episodes everyone click here to learn all about
superior iron man in doctor strange 2 and click it
for my new spider-man no way home deleted scenes
video with tobey mcguire andrew garfield and
all the matt murdock daredevil deleted scenes
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!